Actors are a vital part of any Unreal Engine 5 project, and that's because actors can be
anything that's placed into a level.
Here we have a collection of just random actors pulled from the editor, starting with a trigger
volume.
We have directional light, there's a static mesh, there's a skeletal mesh, a player start,
particle effect, even blueprints and other level interactive icons are all actors.
At its base, we can think of as an actor as something that contains a translation,
a rotation and a 3D scale.
So it's something that we can place inside of the scene and we can move it around, we
can scale it and we can rotate it.
Now it doesn't necessarily have to have a visual representation, but it can't.
Actors can also be spawned and destroyed through gameplay code, whether that be C++ or blueprints.
Let's pop over to the editor now and take a look at some actors.
Well inside of the content examples here, this is an actor, this BP demo display, and
if I click on the details panel, notice there are some things that I can change with that.
And it's going to be true for many of the actors that you place.
So if I come up here to quickly add, and I come here to add maybe like a point light,
you can see here with my point light selected in the details panel, I'm going to have many
different properties that I can select.
And again, as I go through here, I can select many different types of actors and they're
going to have many different types of properties.
And this is why it's so critical to understand what actors are.
And it's not complicated.
Remember actors are just simply the term for objects that can be placed or spawned into
any level that you're working with in Unreal Engine 5.